um in fact I want to show you something
I brought this just broke this is a
Harvard case on that situation it's been
published in 91 countries I'm right at
the center of it it's called Kevin oer
building a brand in shark invested
Waters it goes right at the FTX
situation I lost about $16 million there
as a paid spokesperson I looked like an
idiot during that time and so did many
others because this to me was a startup
and this case goes through exactly what
happened and why I'm still here if you
have employees you need to check out the
ERC program Chef wonderful why Mr
Wonderful because it's cash flow that
you don't have to pay back good to know
this guy's so smart and so handsome go
to wonder trust.com to see if you're
eligible